country the impeachment must go for
joining me to discuss her Lila Alphonse
managing editor for US News World Report
nice to see you Lila David Pakman host
of the David Pakman show nice to meet
you by the way Thank You own you a long
time my colleague WGBH reporter Adam
Reilly I've been following you too for a
long time so we all really do these
things after debate where me and my
co-workers pick what we considered
became moments and then you give us your
feedback we decided this time to allow
you to pick what you thought was a major
moment since you're the new kid on the
block here tonight what was a major
moment for you I was when Elizabeth
Warren was pressed about can you say yes
or no whether taxes generally speaking
will go up under your health care plan
she had a pretty good debate overall but
I don't think this was her best moment
here is that moment let me be clear on
this costs will go up for the wealthy
they will go up for big corporations I
will not sign a bill into law that does
not lower costs for middle-class
families I do think it is appropriate to
acknowledge that taxes will go up
they're going to go up significantly for
the wealthy and for virtually everybody
the tax increase they pay will be
substantially less substantially less
than what they were paying for premiums
and out-of-pocket expenses ladders
pretty straightforward question I came
after him saying zero copay zero Prem's
why doesn't she just answer the question
don't know I mean that this has been
workshopped so many times time and time
again I've been talking about this for a
year you can say total cost will go down
doesn't really matter if your payroll
tax goes up a little bit in total what
you pay goes down that's the focus
you know it's my assessment based on
nothing except I think common sense and
she's worried if she says taxes in a
sentence it's gonna be in an ad but it
seems to me what's gonna be in an ad or
the 3,000 times yeah she refuses to
answer the question it's sort of a
damned if you do damned if you don't
situation but when you hear Bernie
Sanders make the case that you know yeah
your taxes might go up a little bit
you're gonna save all this money on
deductibles copays the other stuff that
you're paying right now he does it in a
way where it's almost impossible to
imagine it being packaged as an attack
yet why she can't do the same I don't
know one thing I would just add is I
don't buy the idea among media observers
media critics that it's unfair for
journalists to press her on this because
a Republican talking point it has
completely legitimate and her ability to
handle the question and give an
effective answer gets to her strength or
lack thereof I can see how the corner of
my eye you're nodding in agreement
meaning it was not a great moment for
her um I think I agree that she's damned
as she does dev as she doesn't I think
she's trying to let Bernie Sanders have
the the terrible moment of saying your
taxes will go up and I don't think it
has that the adverse effect that she's
worried it'll has I don't see why it's a
damned if you do call her a radio show
today said pick the number the average
family pays on health care let's make up
twenty four thousand dollars for family
your taxes are going to go up twelve
thousand dollars so you're gonna pay
less I mean end of discussion
I think that no matter what number she
picks or what what economic level she
picks people will focus on the fact that
there's an increase instead of on the
overall costs going down which is the
real answer but when a politician
refuses to answer any question
repeatedly does the voter not assume
that the answer is no that's what I mean
that's what I mean about damn say
there's also in the background of this
question the the question that keeps
coming up about Elizabeth Warren says
Medicare for all is the gold standard
dot-dot-dot she's open to different
solutions she's open to other solutions
and that's kind of not explicitly said
well the judge gave her room food
intelligence by saying Medicare for all
those who wanted mean right and keep
your private insurance if you choose she
wasn't buying that it's absolutely what
was your mom no just really briefly it's
almost become that the National Club no
I've quit a lot of Charlie Baker not
riding the T right the question why
doesn't he just ride it to ride those he
already and the longer you wait to do
the part he did eventually the longer
she waits the harder it gets what moment
you put I picked the moment where Joe
Biden yelled at Elizabeth Warren
basically saying you should appreciate
the fact that I got you the consumer
financial press there it is there's
Biden and the response I agreed with the
great job she did and I went on the
floor and got you votes
I got votes for that bill I am deeply
grateful to President Obama who fought
so hard to make sure that agency was
passed into law and I am deeply grateful
to every single person who fought for it
and who helped pass it into law but
understand did it he'll that job you job
thank you
little condescension on both sides no I
see the condescension [ __ ] on his part
I see her being appropriately prickly
given that she helped drive the creation
of this thing and what I love about that
exchange is I feel like it shows that
Biden whatever strengths he brings to
the table is kind of a loose cannon who
people might like that he gets
passionate worked up about things but it
doesn't always work in his favor and
then her response I think shows what an
artful debater she is and how much
better she is than him at handling
moment okay I was gonna go to you but
before we go to you in a second on your
pick from last night since you mentioned
Biden here if you didn't know that he's
a former vice president if you didn't
know that he was leading in all the
polls until recently now he's in second
place
what would your takeaway be on Joe Biden
from last night well especially in that
moment I mean he was doing an attempted
kill shot as I like to say Kamala Harris
had the big one in the first or second
debate against Joe Biden but the thing
about those is especially the longer we
go into this thing you might get a
little bump in the polls in the short
run from those if they go well in the
best case but they fade and Kamala
Harris is polling doubled and dropped
right back down to where it was I would
feel as though just seeing that and not
knowing the polls he's trying to come
from behind and execute one of these
killers my sense was he just wasn't
ready for primetime yeah yeah yeah I I
watched it and thinking why is he still
being seen as the front-runner even
though he's not polling as the
front-runner but that moment I think
will resonate with a lot of people as a
guy trying to take credit for what the
woman got done and I think her answer
was really appropriate she I mean yes
that's his job to get votes but she's
thinking the person she's thinking Obama
you could hear them what was your moment
so my moment was when Kamala Harris
brought up reproductive health because
that's something that didn't come up at
all in the last debate it hasn't come up
that much in the other debates before
that and it's something that tends to
start an end with Planned Parenthood and
it's much more than her Senator Harris
on that very point this is the sixth
debate we have had in this presidential
cycle and not nearly one word with all
of these discussions about health care
on women's access to
reproductive healthcare which is under
full-on attack in America today and it's
outrageous it's not counterpoints I know
you wonder you think it was a good
moment for her but she's had a really
tough time since that moment David
mentioned in the first debate is this
helper I think it does help her with a
certain segment of the voting population
I think it does help a lot I think it
helps her because she looks like she's
trying to turn the spotlight to some
things that are maybe not getting enough
light but I'm not sure that it would
really have a lasting effect you know
can we go down the list if we can we
talked about button Elizabeth Warren
down list other than that tax moment
last night I mean the good news that
soon for her is you have to watch a
debate and say that she must be the
front-runner you don't look at polls
because everybody's targeting her yes
that's good yeah I think that's terrific
and other than her struggle on tax is
nothing really stuck you know people
were throwing all sorts of stuff at her
and no one I think got the better I was
gonna say targeting her but also asking
her to join forces with them are you
gonna stand with me on having the
president's account shut down on Twitter
are you gonna stand with me on ending
endless wars or a regime change war yeah
exactly so I think that's also what
indicated that she's in front agree I
generally agree I do think though the
the further we get into this thing the
debates are not going to move the polls
very much unless someone has a terrible
terrible night because the positions are
more known the candidates are more known
I think there's way too many people on
the stage at this point the requirements
need to be brought up but it's gonna be
hard to move the polling with these
debates so Sanders I have to say I
thought after the heart attack and not
be on the campaign trail for two weeks
cooked absolutely done dropping in the
polls he not only has what I consider be
a pretty spry night you know 74 eight is
someone said today is the new 75 or
whatever you want to say but then he
announces a special guest is coming to
his rally in Queens who happens to be
maybe the most sought-after
progressive endorse or mark Ocasio
Cortes over the weekend did he put
himself back in the mix so he did as
good a job as you can of from a stage
proclaiming that your health is fine
right I mean you know we're not seeing
him playing basketball we have videos
from a year ago we don't know how is
that jump shot would look right now I am
unsure how much the endorsements will
help because they're coming from people
who are for the most part
already part of the same coalition and I
think generally speaking someone who
will be paying attention to what a OC or
the others say are probably already
supporting but doesn't it say that
Warren is not the the the absolute
winner of the progressive vote doesn't
it challenge that notion a little bit
until until Nestle endorses her right
but she's a local I mean what she says
but she's the home yeah I think it's not
going to move the needle and the thing
that's tough for Bernie is that the
numbers if he goes after Biden Biden's
supporters choose Warren as their number
two same thing Warren Biden that makes
the math here and these numbers have
been steady throughout you've seen Biden
have what looked like an insurmountable
lead at one point yeah sort of trended
down Warren has had to study rise and
Sanders just flatly so the two moderates
who I think at the best night last night
put a judge and clove ashore
do they begin to sneak into the Biden
position or I don't think they have yet
I think they made some really good
points but I don't see this moving them
up very much in the polls I think people
tend not to look at them yet as the
presidential candidate I think they see
them as cabinet members I think they see
them as high-ranking cabinet members and
maybe a VP pick but there are two people
who I don't really think people are
looking at them in terms of can this
person be the president you're speaking
to be the president most polls show the
issue that matters most the Democrats is
who can beat Donald Trump even if I'm
not crazy about he or she stands for if
he's the most she is the most likely to
beat Donald Trump um he or she is not
that person
did anybody how do you demonstrate that
you're the most electable of a group
other than holding up a poll that shows
you to be did anybody do that last night
on that stage I don't think anyone in
particular did it from the frontrunner I
think that one of the arguments that the
people the ones and twos as I call them
are trying to make is that despite the
fact that they have no support and will
probably be gone before the next debate
as they probably should be
mathematically at this point that they
are particularly electable in facing off
against Donald Trump I don't think
anyone made a particularly strong case I
mean I sound like I'm a huge Elizabeth
Warren cheerleader I like to think I'm
critical of her when appropriate but I
thought she demonstrated the most
facility it's easiest to imagine her
hanging with
a trump on a debate stage it's harder
for me to imagine Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders probably helped his cause there
I think Bernie would do well I think
although you know the polling doesn't
suggest he's going to be there I think
Andrew yang has a particular demeanor
that might make him well-suited to
debate Donald Trump without commenting
on his positions on issues I think
that's something I think Elizabeth
Warren I could see her on the stage but
I still can see Joe Biden on there
because I think especially in the third
hour where he kind of came a little bit
unhinged got a little bit less
controlled less calm I think that's what
people are looking for to go up against
Trump so do you I'm James against the
unhinge because I think still people are
still looking for infotainment here you
can see Biden's staying in this race to
the end I can only because people are
looking at him in terms of can he beat
Trump at his own game not just can he
beat Trump can he beat Trump at his own
game and I think that's what he's got
going for him is he the best candidate
on that stage I think everyone has a
different opinion on that and I've you
know I can see the Elizabeth Warren
going out there I can also see Elizabeth
Warren kind of falling victim to what
Hillary Clinton did with the you have to
be very nice or you have to rise above
or you have to not be affected by any
bad things on that and during that
debate and have it turned against her
yeah the last ten seconds I want to
flash back what you said about the
moderates going after Warren to show
that they're the most electable some of
those lines were gonna see I think the
Republican attack as what was people who
judges fray she's looking for endless
partisan conflict they need to be
mindful of the fact that those words can
be used against the Democratic nominee
done okay it's on to Georgia I think
it's November 25 nice to see ya extra
leisure to meet you thanks for coming
here